Michael Jordan is selling his majority
stake of Charlotte Hornets which he
bought in uh for 275 million dollars in
2010 a reported 1.7 billion dollars this
would mean a significant profit for
Jordan whose tenure as majority owner
saw the team uh reached only the playoff
Birds two times and no second round of
the postseason the bankruptcy of teams
local media partner Diamond Sports Group
could put the future meteorites of 42.
listen to this folks MLB NHL and NBA's
teams in Jeopardy representing an
existential threat to the League's teams
like the Hornets whose games are aired
on Valley Sports Southeast rely heavy on
the cable and NBA attributed 13 of last
season's earnings to local media deals
Jordan may be looking to downsize his
ownership role due to struggles as an
owner and instead to focus on other
Ventures such as his Nike brand or his
new NASCAR team a deal is not imminent
but if he decides to move on he may not
find a better opportunity Tom well I
think a buyer is also going to find out
opportunity here and what has happened
these local sportsnets Valley Sports if
you Google that you see what happened to
them that is critical I've I've been
reading it's anywhere from 13 to 20
percent depending on the team so in
other words if you're the owner and you
suddenly lose 13 to 20 percent of you
know what's coming in you're gonna have
to reach into your pocket next year and
cover the difference because you've got
existing player contracts you've got
existing leases on your stadium so
Jordan's in a good place because he
bought it such a compelling price and
the franchise is worth 1.7 so even if
someone came along and said yeah I'm
only going to pay you one three one four
or some number he can still make a good
a tremendous deal on it and someone is
still going to get a deal on the team
but that someone is still gonna have to
figure out the gap on these local sports
it's happening all over baseball and
it's happening here this is just where
the the economics of the time in which
we live these um Regional Sports Nets
even with great advertising you get more
advertising for live programming because
people don't fast forward through it and
they don't like you know watch it on DVR
later and then skip so all that's coming
home here but this could be a win for
Michael Jordan but also a win for
someone that wants to get in as an NBA
owner because I don't think they're
going to pay the price that's in Forbes
because what just happened with the
regional Sports Group that's going to be
a discount effect I'm gonna take a
different angle you talk about a win
from Michael Jordan uh MJ needs a win at
this point in his career because there's
no question he is the goat greatest of
all time NBA you can whoever you want to
put second third fourth fifth you want
to put LeBron you want to put Kobe you
want to put Bill Russell Wilt
Chamberlain throw them all unless it's
all good MJ's number one but on the list
of all-time worst owners in NBA history
MJ's on Goat Mountain it's been so
different than Donald Sterling uh worse
than Phoenix listen Goat Mountain yes
Phoenix has been to the finals before MJ
how many times has he even been to the
play
the Phoenix owner has proved to be a pig
the reality is this uh what we've
realized with MJ is that as great as you
are as a player it doesn't mean anything
as an owner or general manager listen
I'm a huge Miami Heat fan I've been to a
million games season tickets
um we've won multiple championships with
the Heat Dwyane Wade Shaq the whole
Squad everything that we've done over
here when we see Charlotte Hornets who's
in our division show up on the calendar
it's like just throw a w right there
because this team doesn't do [__] and
you would assume that if MJ is the owner
of your team
there's going to be some MJ magic you're
gonna maybe make it to the playoffs
you're gonna make a run nothing the only
thing they have to speak of is they have
lamelo ball who again broke his ankle
this year yeah so talk about breaking
ankles in the NBA it's just I'm an MJ
fan I mean I'm a Isaiah Thomas fan to be
honest with you Pistons Bad Boys but I
want to see MJ succeed as an owner I
want to see his team do well
unfortunately they're just trash so why
don't you Adam what would be the the
reason and you think behind somebody
with that much knowledge for the game
that much power that many relationships
that he can't turn a team like that
around
why do you think that yeah I'm curious I
don't know I think it's a combination of
factors I think they haven't had a good
coach in years I think the general
manager hasn't done much I think their
draft picks have turned out turned out
well other than lamello I think the best
player they've had in the last 10 years
has been Kemba Walker he's out of the
league at this point but they had a
Mecca Okafor I just they they have not
put together a good squad and I wonder
why I think it's an opportunity
um I'm sorry Pat no no go ahead I think
it's an opportunity that is why if I was
in Charlotte first of all North Carolina
is like basket Indiana North Carolina
and Kansas is like the two most natural
basketball states of the nation you have
Duke you have UNC Chapel Hill you have
NC State and the legend of Jimmy Valvano
you have Wake Forest uh Tim Duncan went
to Wake Forest I think I believe yeah so
you you have this in this basketball
crazy State that's crying for an owner
that cares enough to reverse everything
that you just correctly pointed out the
checklist you just gave I agree with but
I think there's an opportunity for
someone to do it and Charlotte although
is the second capital of the U.S banking
industry as we know it's known as the
second capital you would think there'd
be some money there but banking's got a
little here's what's going on here's
what I would say wise move because MBA
is a shitty product today and take your
1.7 billion go put it elsewhere you're
going to get better returns than leaving
it in the NBA do I think the NBA
franchise you know is it going to double
in the next decade yeah is it going to
get 7 7.2 percent over the next decade
maybe who knows but maybe he can he's
going to get 7.2 percent the other part
is you know to to choose to be an owner
it's a different it's a it's a very
different philosophy to be an owner than
it is to be a GM than it is to be a
coach than it is to be a superstar than
it is to be a benchwarmer the same
mindset doesn't work when you're owning
a team when you're owning a team it
can't be about the owner it has to be
about the player it's a very very
different Dynamic when you're wanting to
go that route anyway eventually it needs
to be more about somebody else that
hasn't happened here yet but if you're
buying a sports team today I don't know
if I'm buying an NBA team it's a waste
of time to go to see any father that's
thinking about spending a thousand
dollars to take his son to watch LeBron
play to watch uh Curry play to watch you
know anybody play except for a couple
players that won't miss a game anybody
that's thinking about spending a
thousand dollars there is a high
likelihood that your favorite player may
not play on that day why the hell would
you take your kid with a thousand
dollars that you have to go watch the
game knowing the best player may not
play in a season game it's a shitty
product today there's better products
than the NBA to consider playoffs
different story but season I think NBA's
a is not a good product today so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]